well my girl we see we're we're out in
my friend's farm and we see a glider
we see a glider oh the people that are
just like no no that's hang gliding
then there are there are planes where
you you're it's a glider oh yeah no
no engine and they're just like that's
right now i don't know if you know how
they do this but
my girl says i've always wanted to get
in a glider
to which i always go i don't give a [ __ ]
about gliders no i don't care about
hot water i don't care about hot air
balloons gliders
all that [ __ ] is passed for me all of it
just i'm a party pooper but your
girlfriend's going to go
she's dying to go on a glider let her go
we go
we go which is five minutes down the
road in this big open field
and uh they you know how they get you up
in a glider
yeah they have to uh by another plane
pulling you right that would be like one
way that would be one way super safe
yeah because people get [ __ ] up but
just going a regular plane though you
know
in this case they just had on remote
control a cable
that will pull you and you'll do you'll
get to 60 miles an hour in two seconds
it just goes and it's just cable along
the ground that
kicks you up and you got to know how to
i guess
ride it but sometimes a cable breaks and
it's a bad day for you
and then they just get way up here they
get way up in the air and they just
they just you know so did she do it or
no no
but she wanted to is is there a
professional steering that [ __ ] thing
well there's a there there's a club
there and now here's the thing about
that
i got caught up in the glider club
because they came over and started
talking to us about
how there are great places dude you know
what now
the glider club i bet the diversity is
ridiculous
i bet dude it's just a melting pot it's
such a mess of diverse
so many it's like the united nations
so many black people who belong to well
they have guys attached to their car
yeah yeah no there's a lot of color yeah
there's not they're not old
english people yes in terrible clothing
at all yeah
no um and by the way when you're when
you're in a glider
it's i believe it's english law you must
wear a parachute well
the the advantage of gliding is you
don't there's no engine so you can
hear everything yeah there's no
advantage
i'd say there's no way let's go let's go
in a plane without a motor
yeah and then you just glide around and
it's super quiet i guess it's peaceful
did you and your girl get in a fight
about it because she want to do that
stupid [ __ ]
no i just i i was going to say you can
go yeah i go you go i'll watch from here
yeah oh you know what i'll do honey i'll
uh record my phone i could give a
[ __ ] about gliding and they have them
you train a paper plane
in trailers yeah or they or they have
them
dragging behind you know and while we're
at it
there are certain hobbies like horseback
riding that's another one you better
have
all the money and and the upkeep and you
ride the horses
in a ring and it's very i i just i
i'm not into it man horseback riding for
me is like zip lining you go once you're
like
i'm good man and there's like how long
are we on this for the next four hours
i'm on this horse for four years in
costa rica that was the worst
jay we went to costa rica yeah yeah you
go once like oh wow this is pretty cool
up here and then they're like how many
more like
oh you gotta travel the whole jungle and
back like oh [ __ ]
see ya god oh [ __ ]
that's it get the [ __ ] out of here zip
fighting
that's it dude yeah